ANDREW BUNNER: Cool.
Thanks everybody for coming.
AKSHAY KANNAN:
Let's get started.
Hi, everyone, I'm Akshay Kannan.
ANDREW BUNNER:
I'm Andrew Bunner.
AKSHAY KANNAN: And
in this talk we'll
cover Nearby, a set of cross
platform APIs for devices
to discover and communicate
with the things around them.
We'll start by talking about
the Nearby Messages API, which
lets devices find each
other and communicate simply
by being near each other,
without having to be connected
to the same Wi-Fi.
Next, we'll talk about how
you can use that same API
as our recommended way
to scan for BLE beacons,
along with best practices
for things like background
scanning.
And finally, we'll
leave you with a preview
of something new which
we're excited to unveil
for the first time ever today.
Let's get started.
Our devices today have
made it easy to communicate
with anyone, whether
they're right next
to you or on the other
side of the world.
However, a lot of
those interactions
can feel cumbersome if
someone or something
is right next to you.
And often that's the case today.
It takes several
steps, whether it's
exchanging contact information,
scanning a QR code,
or pairing via Bluetooth, just
to get some information over
to a nearby device.
And we believe this
shouldn't be the case.
Ideally, you should be able
to just walk up to something
and interact with
it the same way
that we do in the real world.
Physical awareness
can significantly
improve the experiences
in our apps.
Whether it's facilitating
device to device communication,
real time collaboration,
or experiences
that are triggered by a beacon.
With Nearby we've created
a simple set of APIs
for anyone to bring
proximity into their app.
ANDREW BUNNER: So we've been
working towards this vision
for awhile.
In 2014 we launched
a feature called
Guest Mode on Chromecast.
Now in the past, you had to
be in the same Wi-Fi network
in order to cast.
But with Guest
Mode, you can just
sit down, hit Cast, and put
your content on the big screen.
Now to make this
possible, to prove
that you're in the same
room as the cast device,
we use a combination
of radio signals
and an ultra sonic modem.
And it's great when you're
over at a friend's house.
Works on iOS, works on Android.
And we would like more
cross device interactions
to be as smooth as Guest Mode.
So in 2015 we took
the technology
that powers Guest Mode, and we
made it available via an API
we call Nearby Messages.
It's a simple,
publish subscribe API
for message passing
between devices that
are physically close together.
It's available on Google Play
Services for Android and iOS
via CocoaPod.
Now because it's
cross platform, you
don't have to segment
your user base.
So that means Android
users as far back
as Gingerbread can talk to
iOS users going back to iOS7.
So we think that's pretty neat.
There's a number of great
apps that are using it today.
And more developers are
discovering it all the time.
AKSHAY KANNAN: We'll soon
dive into the details of how
you can call the Nearby
API, as well as how
it works behind the scenes.
But first, we want to show you
examples of the experiences
that developers
have build with it.
My favorite podcast app on the
Play Store this Pocket Casts.
I found a great
podcast the other day
that I wanted to
share with Andrew.
Sharing typically takes me
through a list of contacts
where I have to search
for and pick out Andrew,
even though he's standing
right next to me.
ANDREW BUNNER: (WHISPERS)
I'm right here.
AKSHAY KANNAN: And I don't
already have Andrew's contact
information, it's even worse.
We have to exchange contact
information before being
able to do anything.
So instead Pocket Cast has
built a much more compelling
experience for comparing
podcasts with the people
around you using Nearby.
Let's check out
what it looks like.
So Andrew and I both swipe
over to the Nearby section
of the app.
And we tap Search.
And at this point
Pocket Cast publishes
each of our list of
podcasts over Nearby.
And I get can see
Andrew has some pretty
interesting podcasts.
ANDREW BUNNER: We've got
the bases covered here,
but I see you're missing
The Adventure Zone.
It's hilarious.
Highly recommend it.
And fragmented.
AKSHAY KANNAN: Awesome.
All I have to do is tap,
and now I have them.
Pocket Cast uses Nearby to make
it really easy to share content
within their app.
Another great example, Trello,
is a popular team collaboration
tool that lets you
get things done
with the people around you.
Trello allows you
to create boards
that give you a shared
perspective on a project's
tasks.
With Nearby Trello has made
it easy to quickly start up
collaborations.
With one tap you could
share a board nearby,
making it available
to the people
around you without having
to type in email addresses.
The board is online,
so Trello can simply
pass around a pointer to the
back end object over Nearby
to enable this experience.
Pocket Cast, Trello,
and several other apps
are live on the Play
Store today using Nearby.
So you can install them and try
to experience out for yourself.
In fact, we launched this
API in July of last year.
So some of you may already be
using it in your apps today.
ANDREW BUNNER: All right.
Thanks Akshay.
I'm going to walk
you through how
it works, what it
looks like in code,
and then go into some
details on the permissions
and the privacy.
So let's start
with how it works.
We've got these two calls,
publish and subscribe.
They're for passing messages.
But what actually happens?
So when your app
calls Nearby, we
allocate a short lived
pairing code to your device.
And then we use a
variety of means
to get that code across the air
gap to other nearby devices.
And then any devices that
detect the same code,
they can then exchange messages.
So it's a little different
from traditional location
in that it's very hard
to spoof these codes.
Now by default, we use
a variety of tricks
to get this code from
one phone to another.
Bluetooth Classic, Bluetooth
Low Energy, and Ultrasound.
Now using all three
of those helps
insure that Nearby works across
just the widest possible range
of devices.
So both Bluetooth Classic
and Bluetooth Low Energy
are 2.4 gigahertz radios.
This is the same part
of the spectrum as Wi-Fi
and old fashioned
cordless phones.
And those radio waves
go through walls.
One of the reasons Ultrasound
is an important part
of our offering is that it
does not go through walls.
And that privacy
mode kind of mirrors
what people expect
in the real world.
If I can see you
and talk to you,
you can hear what I'm saying.
But if you're in the next room,
maybe in the line outside,
you can't.
And that's very powerful.
And it gives a sharing use
case a sense of privacy
that's hard to achieve
with Bluetooth alone.
And a side benefit
is that we found
that using audio in this way,
it really does work just about
everywhere.
Every phone has a speaker,
every phone has a microphone.
And it turns out
they all work pretty
well in this part
of the spectrum.
In fact, as we learned
working with Chromecast,
and more recently,
Google Play Movies,
televisions are also pretty good
at making sounds we can't hear.
So it's quite versatile.
This video that you see
over here on the side,
this is a frequency domain
plot of our audio signal.
That bump on the far
right, that's our data.
It starts around 18.5 kilohertz.
And it trails off
round 20.5 kilohertz.
So technically, that's
near ultrasound.
And incidentally,
this is a screenshot
of an app, Speedy Spectrum.
And we had to use this during
the development of Nearby
because none of us could tell
if the phones were actually
making any sounds.
None of us could hear it.
Another reason for
that is that the sound
is coming out of these pretty
small speakers on a phone.
And it's just not a very
high amplitude sound wave.
And that's OK.
We don't need much
energy in the sound
in order to decode
it on the other side.
So if we take this signal that
you see there and slowed it
way down, basically shifting
into a range that you can hear,
it would sound sort
of like a static hiss.
And that's because it's
a spread spectrum signal.
So here's how that works.
We take our pairing
code, and then we
use that to modulate some
prearranged static noise.
And by encoding our
data inside that static
we basically make our
modem robust to echoes
and other interference.
So it really does work
just about everywhere.
So enough signal processing.
Let's take a look
at some code and see
how you can use all this.
We're going to start
with the general use
all the technology
sample on Android.
And here it is.
It's just these two calls,
publish and subscribe.
You call publish to
make your message
available to nearby devices.
You can think of the message
as what your phone says.
And then you call subscribe
to receive messages
from a nearby device.
That's how you listen.
Now the message, it's
just a byte array.
You can put whatever you want
in there with whatever encoding.
So JSON, protocol buffers,
whatever's easiest.
The only restriction is that has
to be less than 100 kilobytes.
So that means it's good for
sending authorization tokens,
or invites, or identifiers,
but not for larger content
like images or movies.
So if we go back to the
Pocket Cast example,
they publish the
list of the podcasts,
not the bytes of the
audio tracks themselves.
And here's the iOS version.
It's very similar.
It's got square brackets.
And it's got 100% of feature
parity and compatibility
with the Android version.
And we're very proud of that.
Now this earshot feature,
this is something special.
If you want to make your message
available only to devices
in the same room,
this is how you do it.
Now there's thousands of lines
of correlation math and signal
processing, and under the hood.
But you have to
worry about that.
You just call set Distance
Type Earshot, and that's it.
Very simple.
Last, I want to talk about
privacy and transparency.
So we think it's
important that a user know
when an app is using
Nearby, and that they
know what's actually happening.
So before an app
can call Nearby,
they have to get permission.
So this is our runtime
permission dialog.
And we're going to show this
when an app calls Nearby.
It explains what radios and
what sensors we use and how.
And in fact, tapping
on Learn More
will give the user as
detailed an understanding
of what's happening under
the hood as the developer
reading our documentation.
And that's on purpose
in both directions.
We want the user to
be informed, and we
want the developer to be able
to focus on their features.
So it's basically-- this
dialogue, by the way,
this is a once per app thing.
So it's really similar
to Marshmallow's
runtime permissions.
We just took those rules
and back ported them
to Gingerbread.
And this is kind of
an important point,
you don't have to
change your manifest.
Because it's a
runtime permission,
you don't have to
change your manifest.
You can just add the feature
without worrying about breaking
automatic updates.
But because we are going
to show this dialogue,
you want to have the user do
something explicit to access
your Nearby feature.
And that way, when
we show the dialogue,
it's connected in
the user's minds,
with the action
that they just took.
So maybe have a special
screen like Pocket Cast,
or a widget that turns
it on like Trello.
So the user is in control.
They're asked for
permission and context.
And the app developer
doesn't have
to worry about breaking
automatic updates.
Oh, and there's one more thing.
There's a notification
there you see.
When an app has an active
publisher subscribe going,
this shows up.
And from there, the
user can hit Stop,
or they can even
revoke the permission.
So total control to the user.
So we've just seen
how easy it is
to peer to peer features
to your app with Nearby.
I want to talk about
using Nearby with beacons.
So beacons are these
simple transmitters.
They're often disconnected
and running on a battery.
And emit identifiers.
These are 31 byte
strings that you
can use to mark important
places or objects.
And then your app and scan
and get these identifiers,
and then figure out if the user
is near something of interest.
There's a number of apps
that are doing this today.
And generally they're using
the platform APIs directly,
or they're using an open
source library on top.
I'm going to try to
convince you-- now
if your apps scans
for beacons, I'm
going to try to
convince you to switch
from whatever you're
doing now to using
this new version of Nearby.
And we've got several
reasons for this.
And I think after
we share these,
I hope you'll agree that
Nearby is a great way
to interact with beacons.
We really wanted to make
this worth your while.
I think we did.
So we've got three reasons.
Let's start with this one.
So this is for
developers who-- they
want the app to
scan for beacons,
but they've been afraid to add
the Bluetooth admin permission.
Now we want users and developers
to have a consistent permission
story around beacon scanning.
And today that's
just not the case.
On Marshmallow, you
can scan for beacons
if you have access to
fine grained location.
But on Lollipop and below,
you need the Bluetooth admin
permission.
And unless your app
was doing something
with beacons from
the very beginning,
you probably don't
have this permission.
And adding it is going to
break your automatic updates.
And that has real business
consequences for many of you.
Also, we're not even
sure it makes sense.
Bluetooth Admin actually let's
do a lot more than just scan
for beacons.
So with Nearby, we are
changing the rules.
When your app scans for
beacons through Nearby,
you only need access to
fine grained location
on all platforms.
So we took the Marshmallow
scanning rules,
and we portered them back to
Jelly Bean MR2 when we first
introduced beacon scanning.
Again, this is an
important point.
Most apps will be
able to add support
for beacon scanning without
updating their manifest.
The second reason
is you're probably
going to get more scans for
free just by using Nearby.
I'm going to explain kind
of with an analogy here,
and I hope you'll
see where it's going.
So let's take Wi-Fi.
Now, if you use the
platform's Wi-Fi manager,
you can passively listen
for scan results that
are triggered by other apps.
So you can kind of piggy back
on the scans that they initiate.
But BLE on the platform
has historically
worked differently.
Each app has to trigger a
scan, and then only that app
sees the results of that scan.
But when you scan for beacons
through Nearby Subscribe,
we will do a scan every
time the screen turns on
and all the apps using Nearby
will benefit from that scan.
We'll route any beacons matching
your app's filter over to you.
And if an app explicitly
triggers a scan through Nearby,
again, all the apps that are
using Nearby will benefit.
All you have to do
is tell us which
beacons you're looking
for ahead of time,
and then we'll route beacons
matching that filter over
to your app.
And you'll get to
process those sightings.
Now there's one more
important trigger
that I wanted to mention here,
and that's location history.
If the user has Location
History enabled,
that service will do BLE
scans in the background
throughout the day.
And if it finds anything
matching your app's filter,
again, we're going
to route them to you.
And you'll get to
process those beacons.
So more free scans
when use Nearby.
The last reason is for folks
doing background scans.
Now if you're doing
background scans today,
chances are that you're
scheduling alarms,
you're grabbing
[INAUDIBLE] clocks,
you're using the Job
Scheduler, you're trying
to run a background service.
It's pretty involved.
It's pretty difficult.
And it's actually getting
even harder with Android N.
But if you use Nearby and
we find a beacon of yours,
we will wake your app up
to tell you about it, even
if your app has been killed.
Yes.
That's my one applause line.
Thank you.
So this makes
background scanning
with Nearby just a whole lot
simpler than the alternative.
So again, if any app,
or location history,
or that screen on scan,
any of those scans
find a beacon for
your app, we're
going to relaunch your
app via pending intent,
and you'll get to
process the beacon.
So for all these reasons,
Nearby is our recommended API
for interacting with beacons.
And by itself, I think those
three represent a pretty
compelling argument to switch.
But just in case you're not
convinced, there's more coming.
So we're going to be adding some
features in the coming weeks.
In particular, you'll get
access to the raw ibeacon
and Eddystone frames
directly, you'll
be able to use your own
beacon cloud registry,
and you'll have
distance callbacks.
So we're really improving
this all the time.
And there will be samples
for all this up on GitHub
once the SDK drops.
Again, we think it's a win for
both users and for you guys,
for developers.
If you want to go
deep on beacons,
there's a talk happening
right after this in Stage 4
about the Google
Beacon Platform.
Deep dive on the
proximity beacon service.
So that's Nearby Messages.
It's available today on Google
Play Services for Android,
and on iOS VR CocoaPod.
And we're improving
it every release.
So really, whether
you're using beacons
or you're doing
something peer to peer,
it's just a great way to add
proximity features to your app.
AKSHAY KANNAN: Thanks, Andrew.
Now on to something new.
As you've seen, Nearby
messages gives apps
a powerful set of APIs to
interact with nearby devices
and beacons.
But of course this
requires the app
to be installed in
the first place.
What if you're at a
place, but you don't yet
have the app that lets
you interact with it.
Or perhaps there's
a mobile website
that lets you interact
with something
when you're physically there.
There are often proximity driven
features in apps or websites
that can make our
users lives better,
but not if you don't
even know about them.
We want to solve this problem.
So today we're announcing
a new feature in Android
for you to know about relevant
Nearby experiences, surface
through BLE from the
things around you.
And we're calling this
Nearby Notifications.
So how does it work?
Let's say you purchase
a brand new Chromecast.
Today, the first thing
that you have to do
is to go to the Play Store,
search for the Chromecast app,
find it, download it.
All before you can start
using this brand new device.
Imagine instead if any smart
device you purchase could
broadcast the set up
experience for it,
and with Nearby, you could
get the companion app
and pair with it simply
by tapping a notification.
Another example.
I recently flew
into SFO from abroad
and had to go
through US Customs.
I installed this app,
Airside Mobile Passport,
which allowed me to go through
a much faster line dedicated
to mobile passport users.
With Nearby, my
phone could tell me
that that experience
was available
and let me install the
app with a single tap.
And another more
everyday example.
The target app
has a feature that
lets you scan a product in the
store and see online reviews.
It's an easy way to get more
information about something
before you put in your cart.
And it's extremely relevant
when you're at a store,
but it's tricky to
get to this feature
if you don't know about it.
Once again, Nearby can help.
We aim the solve discovery
in a quiet but helpful way.
So on Android, we're introducing
Nearby not just as an API,
but as a core user facing
feature, and creating
new ways for
developers to expose
relevant experiences over BLE.
You can look for
this in the coming
weeks as part of an update
to Google Play Services.
This will work on
devices running
Jelly Bean MR2 and above.
Here are some examples
of what it looks like.
When Bluetooth and
location are turned on,
we'll show you relevant content
from the beacons around you.
So what does this look
like in the real world?
Let's go back to
the Target example
and imagine that we're there.
I've been running low
on shaving supplies,
so I'm here to stock up.
I'm in the aftershave
aisle trying
to find the perfect product,
and as I'm looking around,
one of them catches my eye.
Caffeinated aftershave.
Could this be too
good to be true?
I need to know if
this actually works.
So I decide to pull out my
phone and check out reviews.
Now normally I'd have to type
in the name of this product
and search reviews about it.
But this time Target
has associated their app
with a Beacon in the store.
When I swipe down
on Notifications,
I see Target, Scan
Barcodes, See Reviews.
At this point, all
I had to do was
turn my screen on in the store.
The only requirement for me to
see this was to have location
and Bluetooth enabled.
My phone doesn't buzz, but when
I swipe down on Notifications,
I get this helpful hint.
Tapping on this
notification launches
me directly into the
barcode scanning experience
in the Target app.
If I didn't have
the app installed,
Target could have
either launched me
to a mobile website, or
directly to their app installer,
which we'll talk
more about in a bit.
And now I can scan the barcode.
[BLEEP] And I can see
that it costs $5.49.
I can tap up to Reviews.
I could see that people have
been pretty happy with it.
It has a 5 star review, and
the reviews look pretty good.
So I'm convinced and I decide
to throw it into my cart.
So this is just one example
of the many experiences
that you can associate with a
place or a device using Nearby.
Nearby introduces an entirely
new surface to Android
for proximity driven discovery.
And we're excited to see
what you'll build with it.
So how do you get started?
There are three types
of content that you
can attach to your Beacon.
First, we support
simple HTTPS web URLs.
These can point to websites
or to instant apps, which
you heard about in the
keynote earlier today.
Second, we support
intents into your app,
along with a URL fallback
to the mobile web for users
who don't have
your app installed.
And third, we're experimenting
with direct app installs.
We're tapping the notification.
We'll let you install the
app even if it's not there,
and then launch you into
the intended experience.
ANDREW BUNNER: That's our other
applause line, by the way.
[APPLAUSE]
AKSHAY KANNAN: It's
still early days
and we want to be careful
to hold a user experience
bar high.
So we have a set of
criteria for early inclusion
in our direct app
install program,
which we'll talk more
about in the coming slides.
So that's Nearby in a nutshell.
There are several
verticals where
we can help users discover
relevant experiences, travel,
museum, sports,
retail, smart devices,
and I'm sure you all find more.
Now I'll hand things
over to Andrew
who will talk more about our
criteria for wait-listed app
installs, along with the
details of how you can
tie your feature to a Beacon.
Thanks, Akshay.
ANDREW BUNNER: So we
expect many of you,
many developers to be interested
in this app install feature.
We recognize that installs
are very valuable.
But we want to be careful
to balance the user
experience against the
overhead of an install.
The instant apps that
you heard about earlier,
those will change that equation.
But for now, for the
traditional app install,
we're evaluating
partner integrations
against some pretty
specific criteria.
And these criteria could
evolve, but in the interest
of transparency, we
want to share with you
what we're looking for.
So the first and the
most important criteria
is your app has a feature
that's relevant at a place
or near device.
If the feature's not
contextually relevant,
then it's just not for Nearby.
The second is that
we want features
that let a user do something.
So not just informational,
will but action-oriented.
And then a third is we're
looking at how broadly relevant
is this notification to all
the people receiving it?
So for example, if you
manufacture a smart device,
like maybe a smart
fridge, and that device
requires a companion app as
part of its set up experience,
than that app is super relevant
to the device's out of box
experience.
It is needed.
Now other sort of ideas
are a little bit harder
for us to evaluate.
So for example, if you
think about maybe sale
information at a store.
Does everyone in the store care
that the sale is happening?
It's a little bit
hard for us to say.
And so for now, we're erring
on the side of caution.
And the fourth is really a kind
of a technical consideration.
You want to be sure that
the user can watch directly
into your promoted feature, like
we did with Target and the bar
code scanner.
If you can't, then
that's something
you'd want to address before
you apply to this program.
So I'm going to take you
through a few of our partners
to give you a sense of the
ecosystem that we're building.
So I'm going to
start with United.
This app has many
features, but I'm
going to zero in
on just this one.
United offers free in flight
movies and entertainment
through their app.
But you have to have the app.
And speaking from personal
experience, if you take off
and you've forgotten
to install this app,
your children will be
disappointed in you.
So reminding the user to
install it when they're still
waiting at the departure gate,
it's both contextually relevant
and it's very useful.
Here's another one that's a
combination of both device
and place.
So at many CVS pharmacies
they have a photo kiosk.
And this lets you print
photos right from your phone.
And compared to uploading
photos to a website,
and waiting for it in the
mail, it's pretty magical.
But the process is even more
magical if you have the app.
And that's because
the app lets you
establish a peer to peer Wi-Fi
connection with the kiosk.
And it makes the photo selection
process much, much faster.
So here again, there's
something that the user can do,
and it's relevant at a place.
So one more.
The Broad.
It's a new modern
art museum in LA,
and they've got a great
in app audio tour.
Now chances are, you wouldn't
listen to this tour at home,
but if you're in
the museum, it's
very relevant to getting the
most out of your experience.
So these are all features
that required an app install.
I'm going to offer one counter
example that doesn't require
our approval because
it just uses the web,
and that's Notre Dame.
So Notre Dame, besides being a
respected institute of higher
learning, is also popular
tourist destination
for its many historic
buildings and landmarks.
And they created a virtual
tour by placing Beacons
around the campus.
And what they did was they
associated each beacon
with a mobile web page that has
more information and maybe even
a story about that
specific place.
Now they've got both an
app and a mobile website.
But in their case,
the mobile web
provided as good an
experience as the app,
and so it was the right choice.
We're taking a
lighter touch when
it comes to Nearby and the web.
Really, we're just filtering
out harmful links and things
that Google search
infrastructure
would classify as spam.
So that gives you an idea
of the kind of feature
that we want to bring forward.
We see Nearby and Android
as helping users discover
new ways to get things done.
So let's get into some
of the technical details.
I'm going to talk you through
how to take advantage of Nearby
in this new way.
One of the great things
about this program
is it doesn't require
any programming.
Most of our partners
were able to get
things to just work with
zero code modifications
to their app.
There is some work, but it's
just on the Beacon side.
So I'm going to get into that.
There's basically
these four steps.
You need to get some beacons.
You need to set them up to
advertise what you want.
Register them with Google.
And then tie them to
your app or website.
So starting at step
1, you need something
that can BLE advertise.
So if you manufacture a smart
device, it's just the device.
But for installations
at a place,
we recommend getting
some Eddystone beacons.
So if you visit g.co/beacons,
we've got links to 15
or so beacon partners
and their web stores.
But if you can't wait to receive
your beacons in the mail,
you can also turn an
Android or iOS phone
into a temporary beacon
just by using the platform's
advertising APIs.
So next, we have to
configure the beacon.
Provision it, we say.
So some of the manufacturers
will do this for you.
And if not, they all
provide companion apps.
This is a screenshot of Radius
Network's Rad Beacon App.
They all look similar
and do similar things.
So again, so far we've
bought some beacons,
we installed an
app, no programming.
Now if you want to use the
physical web or Eddystone URL,
you could actually be done
at this step, here at step 2.
Now the physical web
is an open standard
for encoding a web URL directly
in that identifier being
emitted from the beacon.
It works on Chrome, on
both iOS and Android.
And Nearby is going to
be adding support for it
in the coming weeks.
In fact, there's a
talk tomorrow at 10 AM
actually on this stage.
But if you want
to take advantage
of the more advanced
features, the app
launching, the app
installing, then you
want to choose Eddystone UID
or Eddystone EID at this step,
and then we've got
two more short steps.
So you need to claim
ownership of the beacon.
You can do that with
our beacon tools app.
You just get near the
beacon, select it in the app,
hit Register.
Now besides unlocking the
app install and the app
launching features, this
has some other benefits.
The beacon will show up
in our web dashboard.
And you'll be able
to see it on a map.
You can monitor
its battery level.
Basically the beacon becomes
location infrastructure
that you own.
And last, we need to tie the
beacon to your app or website.
And we do this
with an attachment.
Now if you're an
expert thumb typer,
maybe you're a millennial,
you can do this directly
inside the app, and
enter in all that JSON.
I personally recommend
the beacon dashboard.
It's a web tool.
Again, it's linked
from g.co/beacons.
So let's look at
that attachment.
It's got these fields.
And this tells us what to
put in that notification,
and then where to take the
user when they tap on it.
Now again, the beautiful thing
about Nearby is most of you
won't have to change
your apps to create
these contextual notifications.
There's one tricky part
of this integration,
and that's just this URL.
So I'm going to show you
a little bit more on that.
And we'll provide some
tools and documentation
on how to get this right.
But here's what's to know.
If the URL looks
like the top one,
then we take that to mean that
it requires an app install.
This is the one that
requires our approval.
And we'll have a sign up form
at the end I'll tell you about.
If it looks like the
middle one, then we'll
launch the app if it's
already installed.
And if it's not, we'll go
to the mobile web fallback
that you specify.
No approval required.
And then for the last one, if
it's just a regular HTTPS URL,
we'll just open the web page.
Now for the first
two, the URLs that
are going to launch
an app, you want
to make sure that the scheme
host and path in that URL
matches up to an intent
filter in your manifest.
And that's just so that we
can launch your app directly
into the right screen.
Again, this is all
launching soon,
all documented at
developers.google.com/nearby.
So if you want to
experiment with the app
install feature prior
to being wait-listed,
or you just want to try out
an attachment before making
it public, there's a way to
mark the attachment as debug.
And then once Nearby
rolls out, it'll
show up on phones that are
in developer mode, but not
the general population.
This is the important part.
If you'd like to apply to be
wait-listed for the app install
program, there's a
sign up form again
at developers.google.com/nearby.
Now that sign up form is
geared towards apps like Target
and Mobile Passport.
These are folks who've
got beacons deployed
and they've got a
strong user story
around a contextual experience.
And then of course,
smart devices.
In fact, we actually did some
integrations inside Google
with teams like Chromecast,
and Where to help people
install companion apps.
But we're most
excited to see what
you guys build on top of
this new Nearby Notifications
platform.
So there it is.
We're building
Nearby into Android
is a core feature,
allowing users
to discover things
around them, whether it's
contextual apps for the
place that they're at,
peer to peer
collaborative experiences,
or interactions with
another smart device.
We hope you like it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]